katia bonsoir alors vous êtes au coeur
de l'assemblée nationale où en sont les
débats les débats comme vous son billet
le supposé sont houleux il ya des
protestations des noms d'oiseaux qui
volent par exemple le député communes
sébastien jumel a parlé de joueur de
flûte qui cherche endormir le serpent
puis à de grands protestation notamment
lorsque le président de l'assemblée
nationale richard ferrand a précisé le
cadre des débats alors tout d'abord une
troisième semaine des changes a été
ajouté et puis les députés travers 1 ce
week-end pour s'arrêter le 6 mars en
avant les municipales
richard ferrand a également estimé dû à
la volonté d'obstruction a selon ses
propres termes de certains groupes que
certains justement certains groupes les
fameux ne pourront présenter qu'un seul
orateur au nom de leur groupe saf cela
pour répercussion par exemple pour la
france insoumise qui a déjà déposé 23
mille amendements de ne pouvoir disposer
d'environ 2 puis d'un millier de prise
de parole ce qui est évidemment peu au
regard de tous ces amendements cela a
énormément déplu au groupe en question
est de notre côté avant que les débats
de des mavs nous avons interviewé deux
députés stéphane peu communiste et puis
jean lassalle vous les écoutez sont très
irrités forcément par cette réforme
vous n'avez pas une thune dans l'espace
public et on ne ressent plus bas pour
les lots de la souveraineté des
initiatives que nous pourrions pas nous
n'avons plus ni de se balader politique
nine tune qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire une réforme des retraites qui
interpelle déjà les 17 millions d'euros
nous avons dans nos pays et les millions
qu'ils s'apprêtent à l'oeil a très
rapidement faudrait faire du moins c'est
par là que je commencerai au fond il y
avait pas péril en la demeure
c'était commencé voilà c'est l'espoir ce
gouvernement ne veut pas donner la
parole au peuple
or en démocratie il n'ya pas plus hauts
placés que le peuple pour trancher à un
sujet important pour l'avenir de la
nation j'ajoute que contrairement à ce
que dit souvent la majorité le
gouvernement cette réforme ne figurait
pas dans le programme du candidat
emmanuel macron c'est même l'un verse
puisqu'il avait dit dans son programme
électoral qu'il ne toucherait pas à
l'âge de départ à la retraite alors que
l'on voit bien que l'un des objectifs
principal de cette réforme c'est au
contraire d'allonger la durée de travail
est de reculer l'âge de départ à la
retraite sur deux manière générale lors
des échanges les députés quel que soit
leur bord conteste totalement le contenu
de la réforme et de l'étude d'impact par
exemple boris vallot le député
socialiste a reproché des zones de flou
des uns des impasses de l'étude d'impact
inya selon pas assez d'informations pour
examiner le texte correctement avec des
bases assez solides
donc voici l'ambiance un peu électrique
qui règne en ce moment à l'assemblée
nationale et nous vous tiendrons au
courant de l'évolution du débat